مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه نفذت هجوما
عنيفا استهدف مدرسه العروبه في منطقه
المخيم الجديد بالنصيرات
تدمير المدرسه بشكل كامل اكثر من خمسه
غارات متتاليه استهدفت هذه المدرسه دمرت
بشكل
كامل فرق الانقاذ الطواقم الطبيه طواقم
الاسعاف في جهاز الدفاع المدني كذلك طواقم
الاسعاف في مستشفى العوده يتفقدون هذا
الدمار الكبير ويحاولون الوصول الى
داخل المدرسه الطائرات عملت احزام ناري في
هذا المبنى اللي هو
مدرسه مدرسه العروبه للثانويه طبعا هذه
المدرسه كانت تحوي اللي هو نازحين ما
يقارب من 7000 الى 100 الا نازح في داخل
هذه
المدرسه طبعا تم اخلاء هذه المدرسه بعد
اللي هو توزيع او رمي الاوراق من الاحتلال
انه اخلوا منطقه المخيم الجديد وتم اخلاء
هذه المدرسه بالكامل من النازحين استهداف
في مخيم النصيرات مدرسه النصيرات
الابتدائيه في منطقه المخيم الجديد
استهداف هذه المدرسه ومدرسه مجاوره لهذه
المدرسه ادت تناثر الشظايا الى هذه
المدرسه الى اصابه عدد من المواطنين طواقم
الاسعاف التابعه لجهاز الدفاع المدني كذلك
طواقم الاسعاف التابعه
ل مستشفى عوده في مخيم النصيرات وصلت الى
هذا المكان والى هذه المدرسه لانتشال
الاصابات عدد كبير من المصابين من
النازحين في هذه المدرسه يتم انتشالهم من
قبل طواقم الاسعاف والطواقم
الطبيه مدرسه العروضه بالشكل الموجود يعني
اكثر من مبنى هنا وفي مبنى هنا وفي جوره
كبيره ه تم انتشال حركه ما يقارب 12 اصابه
تم اخذه من مدرسه الوكاله بجانب مدرسه
العروبه يعني تدمير
كامل لمنابر العلم في قطاع
غزه مدرسه العروبه في المخيم الجديد
بالنصيرات
دمرت بشكل كامل